في اوكرانيا اعلن القائد العام للقوات
الاوكرانيه تدمير احدى وعشرين طائره مسيره
وخمسه عشر صاروخا من طراز كروز خلال هجوم
روسي الليله الماضيه واضافت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه ان الهجمات الروسيه تركزت في
اتجاهات دونيتسك شرقيه البلاد كما اكدت
التصديا لهجمات روسيه على محوري لمن
ومارينكا باتجاه
في غرب مسيو تيفا بمنطقه خركيز الاركان
الاوكرانيه ان الغارات الجويه الروسيه
تواصلت على باخموت
اي تقدم بريا في تلك الاتجاهات
من ثياب مع حسام مسعود وماتورده قياده
الاركان الاوكرانيه من معلومات ميدانيه
خصوصا
ما يجري في الجنوب وايضا الاطلاع على وضع
العاصمه اليوم حسان
نعم اكيد شهدت هذه الليله قصفا جديدا
صواريخ وكذلك المسيرات التي وجهت نحو
العاصمه الاوكرانيه بكثافه خلال هذه
الليله كما كانت الليالي السابقه رئيس
الاداره العسكريه تحدث عن هجوم هو السادس
من نوعه خلال الست ليالي الماضيه في هذه
الهجمات المكثفه على العاصمه الاوكرانيه
التي بدات مع مطلع شهر مايو المقبل تتكثف
بشكل كبير كانت الهجمات عباره عن هجمه كل
يومين لكن خلال هذه الفتره الاخيره كان
هناك هجوم كل يوم وباشكال مختلفه اليوم
قياده القوات الجويه تحدثت عن تغيير في
الطريقه التي حاولت فيها القوات الروسيه
قصف العاصمه الاوكرانيه
مرور المسيرات عبر قناه نهر دنيبرو بوصولا
الى العاصمه الاو وكذلك محاوله القاذفات
الاستراتيجيه التوجه من بحر قزوين نحو
المنطقه الجنوبيه وقصف العاصمه بصواريخ
كروز من طرازخه 101 هذه التفاصيل تريدها
القوات الجويه لانها تريد ان تشير ان
القوات الروسيه تحاول خلال هذه الضربات
المكثفه نحو العاصمه الاوكرانيه ان تنوع
من وسائلها ومن طرقها لمحاوله ما وصفته
بتضليل قوات الجويه والدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه ومحاوله الوصول الى العاصمه
هذا هذه الكثافه حسن عندما نتحدث عن هذه
الانواع من الصواريخ وهذه الكثافه
بالاطلاق في حال تمكنت القوات الروسيه
بالفعل من الوصول بهذه الصواريخ الى
العاصمه الى الارض الى اهدافها هذا يعني
ان دمارا كبيرا يمكن ان يحصل في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه
وهذا كله حدث بعد القصف الذي حدث بمسيارات
باتجاه مقر الكرملين في بدايه
ان تفهم العاصمه الاوكرانيه ان هذه
الضربات المكثفه نحو العاصمه هي رسائل
سياسيه اكثر منها ايضا رسائل عسكريه
وميدانيه فقط هذا يحدث في الوقت الذي
تتراجع فيه وتيره الهجمات عند المنطقه
الشرقيه وتتكثف في ذات الوقت عند المنطقه
الجنوبيه نحن نتحدث عن عدد كبير من
الضربات الصاروخيه والمدفعيه على مناطق
خرسون جنوب نيكولايف وكذلك منطقه
زاكولوجيا وفي ذات الوقت ما يحدث في
المنطقه الجنوبيه هو اعلان القوات
الجنوبيه عن انها دمرت عددا من القوات
الروسيه المتمركزه في تلك المنطقه لا سيما
في منطقه